mais vous aviez un deuxième procès dans
d'une cassation vous avez un deuxième
match deuxième procès ça c'était un
petit peu plus rocambolesques de ce qui
s'est passé là-bas alors j'arrive à la
prison de constantine et je rencontre le
procureur militaire et son adjoint et je
demande d'accéder encore à mes documents
parce que j'ai quand même quelques
documents personnels des notes que j'ai
écrits qui arrive avec moi le par avion
il est deux autres personnes se sont
impliquées dans la sphère la conel c'est
hassan et bouabdallah sont aussi sur
l'eau comme témoin pour le deuxième
procès et je vais demander au procureur
d'avoir mes documents et on va permettre
d'avoir mes documents mais en même temps
on va me remettre aussi par erreur des
documents qui appartiennent à monsieur
si hassan le succès à 100 et bouabdallah
eux ont été arrêtés au début de mai 2009
ils ont été perquisitionnés à leur
domicile et la drs venait sûrement
ramassé beaucoup de documents chez eux
et on va me remettre les documents de
monsieur si assad
en prenant une douche environ à peu près
à tous les hommes entrent à tous trois
jouent aux dés 10 jours dépendant des
problèmes de plomberie des problèmes de
un petit peu à la bonne volonté de nos
gardiens aussi baobab le mans et c'était
très froid parce que pas de chauffage
ma cellule mesurer à peu près du pied
par six pieds on nous enfermait dans nos
cellules le soir vers 10 heures
on ouvre à lille la cellule de l'armée
cette heure on avait une espèce de
grande synthe commune on était six quand
même à ce moment là j'étais pas isoler
le colonel bobia l'intello si hassan
depuis deux autres personnes et puis bon
il y avait une vie un peu communautaire
qui était qui était quand même un peu
plus facile mais par contre au niveau de
la nourriture c'était l'horreur très mal
manger justement des j'avais demandé
pour avoir au moins deux tomates pour
avoir des légumes par jour et puis on
disait que c'était trop cher
s'il n'y a pas de problème à ce moment
là si on va l'acheter la tomate
il ya une espèce de début pouvoir
continuellement
j'ai demandé à voir les règlements de
prison au miso jamais montré ben si bnf
lui m'avait pas donné un peu de
nourriture à manger moins bien leur vie
si hassan aussi vont me donner des
choses mais si afin de me donnait
toujours dit ce qu'ils voulaient pas
manger ni fuite alors que jamais j'avais
été pas mal plus maigre qu'elle ne
l'était je recevais presque pas de colis
ce moment et ça presse à qui la famille
les amis ont commencé à s'organiser pour
envoyer dès que j'ai régulièrement mais
on m'envoie des céréales on va d'abord
de chacun des choses comme ça mais on
vous des flux flemme c'est un peu
difficile d'envoyer par courrier
et l'eau faisait en contact avec votre
femme quand même par écrit par téléphone
et en 2010 mon frère vont revenir mes
deux filles ou s'ils vont vont venir me
voir mais ça va être des visites de cinq
dix minutes pas plus et quand catherine
vieille le procureur voluer interdire
nous visitent paroisse rapprocher ce
qu'on appelle et je vous falloir que je
me plaigne encore aux directeurs de
prisons qui vont qui va prendre
l'initiative que je peux sérémé fille
dans mes bras et s'il a soulevé cette
que je vais avoir avec catherine la plus
vieille encore monter dans les cars à
pau alors catherine c'était s'était tapé
12 mai km d'avion aller-retour pour
venir me voir dépensé plusieurs milliers
de dollars pour dix minutes de visite
alors je dis à louise bas par l'avocat
permettront demain jeudi
ne venez plus me voir ne dépensez pas
parce qu'on était en situation
financière catastrophique parce qu'on
avait plus de revenus et on avait pris
quand même des risques moi j'avais pris
des risques financiers pour
soumissionner du projet l'algérie alors
on était on était au niveau de la charge
et dialoguiste ne dépenser plus d'argent
pour venir me voir
ça n'en vaut pas la peine c'est ce que
ça me faisait plaisir de voir les
enfants mais c'était beaucoup plus
important ce qui se passait ici à la
maison parce que je savais pas combien
de temps allait durer
vous n'avez pas votre femme pendant deux
ans non j'ai pas parlé luis pendant deux
ans teint et je la verrais pas parce que
l'un l'ambassade vaut lui interdire pour
des raisons de sécurité de venir en
algérie
alors pendant 40 mois j'ai pas vu le
whif alors c'est la preuve que je parle
au téléphone est bon le gendarme bondir
de paysages où le téléphone et puis en
10 minutes environ
mais il ya d'autres prisonniers qui sont
là qui sont là qui ont leur cellulaire
et on leur enseigne se verrait alors
j'ai été les voir bouger demandez vous
écoute je n'ai pas parlé à ma femme
depuis deux ans j'ai dû me laisses tu
ton cellulaire et là je vais pouvoir
parler environ deux heures de temps avec
loïck peyron vont passer en revue tout
le dos aussi
mais ça fait deux fois qu'on dit vous
avez dû faire une grève de la faim
j'ai fait trois grades l'a fait la
première grève de la faim je les fais tu
pour avoir un avocat
la deuxième grève de la faim je les fais
tu pour rencontrer le procureur
militaire
la dorna et la troisième grève de la
faim je les fait à blida
j'ai écrit pendant une vingtaine de fois
au procureur au juge d'application des
peines au joker pour avoir mes documents
à montendre pour travailler je savais
très bien qu'ils ne donneraient pas mais
je voulais avoir au moins deux réponses
je voulais avoir aussi une trace de
commenge été traités à terme de défense
alors j'ai fait abandonner un résumé la
dette 75 corps ce que je vous ai remis à
l'embauché qui fait qu'il reprend toutes
les lettres que j'ai écrit un mois par
mois avec tous les numéros de référence
pour dire ça fait vingt fois je vous
écris pour avoir mes documents monde one
défense et j'ai été condamné
définitivement
j'ai jamais pu me défendre moi j'avais
demandé à voir mon ordinateur parce que
j'avais des photos de la famille la date
au tapis je voulais écrire aussi je te
fait ce qu'il décrira le même parce que
je devais tout écrire à la main
et puis et ont jamais voulu me donner
une réponse
alors j'ai dit je veux je veux faire je
vous avertis que je fais une grève de la
faim ne serait ce que pour avoir une
réponse oui oui et non dites moi oui ou
dites moi non mais de répondre moi
quelque chose
ouf j'aimerais répondu mon et
s'aggravent daffé alors au bout de deux
semaines deux semaines et demi j'ai
arrêté là de la fin
et l'ambassade du canada est venu me
voir mais bon c'était des visites de
courtoisie
j'avais beau expliquer les choses mais
on me disait toujours qu'on ne pouvait
pas intervenir dans la justice interne
d'un pays c'est peut-être vrai mais j'ai
écouté je procède de des femmes de média
blues et veste et j'ai pas loin j'ai pas
eu le droit à un procès juste et
équitable
j'ai pas pu me défendre je n'ai pas pu
communiquer correctement avec mon bureau
à montréal je n'ai pas pu avoir mes
documents j'ai je n'ai pas pu rien faire
alors appelé le premier procès j'ai fait
cassation comment pour vous laisse en
prison des années tant ce vieil âge et
son canada ballad of le canada je me
demande qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait dans
cette affaire là pour venir me voir en
prison pour savoir si j'allais bien ou
si j'étais pas violenté ou son mauvais
pas ceux de miser en prison parce qu'on
me pose carrément la question je sais
pas qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est la correspondance c'est pire
chaque fois qu'ils pensaient de quoi
vikings mais quand j'écrivais aux emmy
au directeur alors j'ose même pour aller
à la bibliothèque fallait que j'en vois
une lettre au directeur pour les adultes
et je voulais avoir de l'eau fallait que
j'écrive au directeur j'ai voulu
rencontrer le procureur à plusieurs
reprises mais à chaque fois que je
demandais quelque chose il fallait que
j'écris ça va entrer dans le système
scolaire
5les nyse pay qui parce qu'ils sont
obligés de tout lire et beaucoup basis
un bon jeu qui revient des amis parce
que c'est une distraction observateurs à
savoir une lettre dans le monde
aujourd'hui ou au match par courrier
électronique
ça pue la massification mais quinze
jours semaines lettre de mes enfants
écrite à la main je sais merde je tiens
le papillon que la fille aux tenues je
vois lancre qu'elle a déposés sur le
papier c'était comme un petit fils kim
kim éliminer celles qui pourraient bien
mes enfants parce que v alors ça c'est
vraiment spécial de recevoir ni être
vraiment spécial et faire ça faisait du
bien mais pourquoi vous vous écriviez
tout ça vous ne sait exactement tout ce
que vous faisiez toute la correspondance
toutes les demandes pour laisser une
trace dans l'administration algérienne
si les algériens post faire écrire alors
je laissais de trêve tout ce que je
faisais à chaque fois comme on
viana dire qu'on m'empêche est community
où je voulais communiquer où je vais
accéder à mon avocat des cons détourner
mon courrier je tirerai je laisser de
traces en principe qu'il y avait une
enquête
on pourrait retrouver dans
l'administration algérienne tous ces
correspondances mais je vais axer la
bibliothèque fait j'avais accès vont
m'apporter un cahier pour dire voici les
ligues sont allés biotech alors je
choisissais des livres mais à blida dans
la dernière année et demie j'étais
d'abord ballon permettait d'aller à la
bibliothèque
mais j'étais toujours isolée car même
n'était pas en contact avec les autres
prisonniers à part le lot prisonniers le
kit handicapés
c'est ma correspondance ça c'était tout
ce que je faisais à cellule ce que je
mangeais tous les jours pendant le
ramadan cette armada j'avais j'avais
vraiment droit déplore spéciale parce
que je connais pas leurs amateurs je
voulais pas le faire manger devant lui
aussi alors quand j'avais dix visites ni
téléphone mais ça c'est à la fin parce
que j'ai commencé j'ai eu le droit de
téléphoner à la famille je pense
septembre 2011 cinq minutes par mois 5
minutes par mois
on se dit pas grand chose en cinq
minutes j'ai eu le droit aussi de
téléphoner à mon avocat au canada m
laferrière cinq minutes par mois
mais j'avais pas le droit de parler de
ma cause la presse a bien ils vont
permettre d'avoir dix minutes par mois
alors c'est tout ce que je note à chaque
fois que j'ai appelé au canada où je
recevais des visites de l'ambassade
qu'avec à 80 de ma fille est venue
mais c'est sur le non sens et c'est la
visite de l'avocat
la visite de l'ambassade ce que je
reçois comme paquet les échanges de
correspondance
je n'accepte pas ce que vous voyez ce
qu'est ce que c'est fait à 100 je les ai
pas regardé depuis que je suis revenu ça
parfois je les sens et que les montres
personne de ta première à bursa alors
comme on avait très peu de l'oise est en
prison quand l'état lui met en avant
pour penser les squares et les journées
ben je me suis fait un jeu d'échecs
alors j'ai récupéré l'équipe type ce
sens c'est un cavalier région alors pour
donner des couleurs on attend en
paissant dans le café j'ai récupéré des
morceaux de faiblesse et des fils de sam
viateur répond que pour avoir le fin de
la saison et avec elle et une figurine
pour vous
c'était notre budget quel pas moi
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont censées l'atome
celui-ci s'était fait dans ce territoire
une feuille de papier on se fait notre
quadrillage aux échecs comme ça et le 29
au matin le directeur vient boire et il
me dira mars les affaires le camion de
l'ambassade et la roque libère alors
j'ai commencé mes choses en catastrophe
alors on me conduit à l'aéroport d'alger
l'ambassadeur était là madame des
rivières ils m'ont fait signer un
passeport provisoire pour que je puisse
se sortir du pays ils sont venus me
reconduire jusque dans l'avion et pour
le canada
la première chose que j'ai faite dans
l'avion ces chiffres à la clé hôtesse de
l'air chez madmoizelle s'il vous plaît
dès qu'on a décollé à porter moi un
verre de vin rouge est approprié un
verre de vin depuis 40 mois et
le repas dans l'avion on dit toujours
c'est mauvais ce qu'on peut manger dans
un avion mais je vous assure
c'était tellement bon d'avoir un couple
une fourchette entre aimer japon mission
depuis 40 ans c'est un art plastique ce
programme
je vais écouter une fourchette pour
manger trop à ça mais moi j'aime pas
bien dire ça tient la caméra mais je me
suis mis à pleurer dans l'avion alors
quand je suis arrivé là-bas ils ont
gardé les allées les jardins l'avion et
puis les portes se sont ouvertes et puis
on est venu me chercher
déjà de sécurité de l'aéroport ils l'ont
emmené dans une salle et toute la
famille était nue qui m'attendait
ouais ça a été sympathique ouais alors
ça va être chaud au coeur de voir louise
cac 40 plongeait pas vu louise car mois
pour louer
c'est dans ces faits c'est vraiment une
saloperie qui nous a été faite
la bonne question je nage un vêtement va
se poser qu'est ce que vous avez fait la
première journée nous et à la maison ici
la famille est à l'heure et puis ma
fille catherine à foix des rues
bénédictine et ce devrait découvrir la
nourriture aussi je conserve je regarde
toutes les choses qui te moment qui
finalement pas les enfants boers ce
faire ils ont arrêté leurs études
aujourd'hui ils ont repris le beau père
de ma fille fait des études de catherine
l université c'est une très bonne chose
qu'on taxe soit retourner aux études
andréanne la deuxième était aux études
aussi à montréal nous verser du québec
il ya juste mon garçon qui a pas repris
des études il travaille pour une
compagnie de géophysique alors il se
promène un peu partout maintenant dans
province de québec montre aux causes de
ce qui vous est arrivé et a arrêté ses
études
ben on est tombé sans revenus ça a été
un choc pour raisons parce qu'ils
s'attendaient pas à ce que je sois
condamné puis emprisonné pendant six ans
alors non s'était fait est très
perturbant présente
oui c'est peut-être eu serait plus en
mesure que bon en parler c'est eux qui
ont vécu au quotidien et ont aidé en
fait non je bous y aurait-il écoles
effectivement mais est en en profitent
ils sont embarqués ce marché du travail
pour aider leur meilleure financièrement
ce qu'il ya plus de revenus alors ils
ont quadrillé parties travaillent à mes
jeans jean-philippe travailler alors
tout le monde doit participer pour
essayer de le site sauver les meubles
mais quand même
pendant toutes ces années là bas louise
auprès desquels de payer les taxes sur
la maison je vais essayer de remonter
une image fidèle de me remettre au
travail le plus rapidement possible pour
eux par des arabes
on doit aider financièrement j'ai des
amis qui ont mis de l'argent pour nous
aider à traverser les moments qu'on
traverse sexuellement
on est on est supporter financièrement
une chance mais c'est quand même
d'argent qui est empruntée qui voit
qu'ils vont devoir être mis au plus
louise aura commencé à travailler aussi
ça lui permet de sortir de la maison et
de ne vivre d'autre chose aussi parce
que c'est pas terminé en carlo
mais qu'est ce que vous espérez qu'est
ce que j'espère bon on y danse dans la
vague encore parce que les poursuites
sont encore là il ne mélangeons pas les
fêtes vous rencontrer c'est que je veux
quand même un historique de staffeur je
veux que ça se sache
je veux que ça se sache aussi à quels
dangers les entrepreneurs canadiens
s'expose quand ils vont travailler dans
des pays où là qu il ya de la corruption
je veux que ça se sache que si on
dénonce des choses en algérie au maroc
ou en tunisie une autre c'est pile ou en
egypte on risque de se faire mettre en
prison
par vengeance par règlement de comptes
je veux qu'on sache aussi que le
gouvernement canadien
je ne pense pour qu'on peut se fier sur
lui pourrait intervenir dans une cause
de cet ordre là ils sont bien bon les
gouvernements pour nous amener en
mission commerciale l étranger dans ces
pays là mais lorsque nous arrive quelque
chose service kofler il n'a pas été
violée monsieur de même somme était bien
traité environ vous êtes arrivé pour
deux saxos genre de sport là que je veux
je veux que mes droits sont respectés
je vais pouvoir parler des avocats
librement fallait surveiller tout le
temps sans qu'on livre mais mais mais
documents qui sont confidentiels par ces
lignes la confidentialité n'existe pas
avec l'avocat je veux avoir des
documents lorsque je me présente un
court